oh Dire Straits for Magnus he's on the
ropes I don't even I don't even know
what to recommend here Queen C1 rookie
two
it's insane I I can't find a move Hikaru
is doing it he's got 15 seconds to find
a move and Magnus closes his eyes and
goes all in and oh my God
Rook A2 he missed it oh my goodness work
takes me six again Rook takes P6 and
it's over
rotations
oh my goodness he still has something
maybe
both Rooks are sacrificed
oh my God this might be winning by the
way but he only needs a draw as the
match clock expires and Hikaru is
exasperated oh my gosh I'm on Hikaru
it's most mate and it's a draw by
agreement and it's the match he offers a
draw a gentleman's draw and I mean what
a finish it literally comes down to the
and it's a draw by agreement and it's
the match he offered to draw a
gentleman's draw and I mean what a
finish it literally comes down to the
last game and look at the smile on even
hikar